good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast it is Thursday it is a
beautiful day in New York
finally hey Claude how you durn hey Jax
hey everyone happy Thursday hope
everyone's doing well
feeling sprightly and hopefully nobody
has anxiety because that's what everyone
needs in quarantine the less anxiety
that is very very true I'm feeling good
today I didn't work out this morning
which is definitely a win I'm working
out this afternoon though very sad um
and yeah just another day in the queue
there's really no rhyme or reason why
today might be different from all other
days but I'm just gonna take it on as
best I can you know some days there's
just nothing to say you know like it's
no aren't again then here we are again a
is one of those days where there's
nothing special about it like nothing
exciting happening you know I'm having a
little heartburn which is different for
me so that's actually exciting I take
that back it is the first Thursday in
May which means that the new episode of
the redheads has just dropped everyone's
listening to it everyone's loving it
it's so good and like we worked so hard
so much goes into putting out one
episode of the redheads because we all
have to read a book we have to leave
ghetto I did I was just getting like
emotional thinking of like all the work
and effort and love that goes into one
of these episodes we all to get on a
four way zoom we all record our audio
isolated and then we put it all together
like a big Orchestra and so it really is
like hours worth of work just for one
episode and I feel as though it shows
like when you're listening to that
redheads episode you're like damn these
girls are working hard and they're
loving what they do this is just a
passion project on all fronts and it's
fabulous that is fabulous it's actually
quite admirable that like you're not
Margo really but your other co-hosts
like record their own audio because
they're just regular girls you know they
just have jobs they're regular girls
they're not podcast engineers alright
and that's something like you and I have
taken years to figure out it's like our
audio expertise and
quite impressive that just sees regular
girls you now are doing the damn thing
yeah they're definitely doing the damn
thing um once again everyone has totally
different takes on the book so it's
exciting I dropped my I dropped my book
for for the next episode and by the way
we're doing two episodes in May again
because we're still in the queue so it's
a bit of a thriller and I'm excited
that's very fascinating it's nice to be
a part of something in the queue you
know I'm a part of Overeaters Anonymous
we meet online every Wednesday so it
feels good you know to be a part of
something bigger than oneself it's true
it's important in the queue to have the
sense of communities you know like I
have a simple sirs I have the redheads I
have the pellet Roasters that's been
like a definitely big community for me
right now and I think it's great
community building you know on all
friends yeah I have this teeny Swifty's
I've been one of my passion projects
during quarantine is to rebuild my
Instagram account for swifty with no job
the problem with like running a Taylor
Swift fan account is that I run so many
Instagram accounts and you can only be
logged into five so between a girl with
no job Claud with no job the morning
toast toast news network and my fake
Instagram I don't have anything to spare
so I find myself like logging out of Jos
News Network to get into swifty with no
job and it's just so there's so much
instability which is why I don't find
myself consistently be being swifty with
no job and if people were wondering
where she went like she just can't get
logged into her Instagram there's no
space for her but you know what I feel
like five instagrams it's interims Way
of telling you like five is the max and
it is enough you know and maybe there's
a reason why swifty knit with no job
didn't make the top side well swifty
with no job at this current Junction
that doesn't pay my bills and that's why
she's not um if I wanted to swap her out
I would have to swap out my Fenster but
as we spoke about yesterday on tear
toasters like my Finster brings so much
both anxiety but like a level of calm to
my life and I just couldn't live without
it and I love her so ease make your
choices you've made your bed I'm gonna
go lie in it yeah I think that's I think
you've got a nice healthy balance there
and by the way and like you would think
swifty with no job would be like a
passion project but I actually think TNN
is your power
project the Instagram and I really think
you can only have one passion project in
your why not yeah and it's like I
already had two off board pup with no
job
give that account to you like I have so
many [ __ ] it sounds like it's sick
yeah I have on my page jackieo
morning toast pup with no job redheads
and do I have a fifth maybe I could open
it up for swifty yeah but I don't need
you to have swifty yeah no I only have
four wow I have a room for one more at
this time for F insta yeah I think I'm
toward the Twitter app you can toggle
between like infinite amounts I only
have two which is my personal on the
toast but I think that you're allowed to
have like as many as you want
that makes sense for Twitter and
explains a lot yeah why there's so many
fake Instagram I mean fake Twitter
accounts yeah so the Instagram there's a
rhyme and reason and I feel like it's
for the best for everyone agreed well so
that's basically where I'm at I'm just
busy you know organizing my Instagram
accounts very nice yes
that's where I'm at to just working like
a dog oh so on the redheads episode um
Dana every two weeks has been updating
us on her like hair growth because she
hasn't changed her legs once in
quarantine and she neither she no she
showed us on the zoom her leg hair and I
got a picture that I'm gonna post to the
redheads Claudia wait I'm gonna text it
to you right now so you couldn't see it
just I want to compare it to my leg hair
Claudia I've never seen anything like it
in my life so if I had seen your leg
hair I don't believe that you haven't
shaved them once no I swear I haven't
shaved them once okay look at your phone
and by the way this picture will be up
on the redheads account by the time this
episode goes up so just hit to the
redheads that looks like her fiance's
leg no that's longer than any than any
man's leg hair that looks like she put a
wig on her leg wait I don't understand
how leg hair grows like that her leg has
a bob she looks like an animal like an
ape
yeah oh my god I'm shook that's gonna be
so funny when you post it I know it's
like really off-brand for the redheads
account because we're like so
picture-perfect
but you know what take Deena is a part
of the brand and therefore she needs to
be represented oh my god that's so funny
I could not believe what I just saw you
guys are gonna be okay yeah it's really
exciting so I guess that's really most
exciting bit about this Thursday except
for you know the beautiful weather it's
beautiful and the proximity to Friday is
you know must be mentioned
we're so close you guys we're so close
it's gonna be a good weekend I can feel
it I got a lot of [ __ ] to watch yeah I
have a lot of um nothing yeah I got
nothing
love it well maybe we'll do like a zoom
you know like a rowdy om in time it is
eighties time well you know it's like
the zoom tzer's you have to be specific
about them cuz I feel like we got we had
one and it was amazing and then we
wanted to do like so many but they're
only special I think if we haven't done
them in a while no we did one it was
amazing we did it again the next weekend
and it was amazing no we did one like
two days after our amazing one and we
were all like tired and looking at each
other and yeah because people weren't
really drinking but like I think now is
the time to bring back the snz ya know
I've like really been drinking almost
every day in my house but I think we
should we should do an F n Z because I
could use a extra day if I'm gonna be
drinking before so while we have those
plans do you think maybe it should be
time oh for sure it's always time in the
queue you know cuz it's also like never
time um so without further ado T's time
for the past five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast and
today's episode of the morning toast is
brought to you by Athena Club making
time for self-care is so important but
we feel like we spend more time browsing
different websites or running to
multiple stores to get everything we
need than actually taking care of
ourselves Jackie and I are constantly
running around like drugstores
department stores
it's exhausting being a woman and trying
to talk though Athena club does eight
you guys thanks to Athena club we can
find safe high-quality self-care
necessities all in one
without leaving home athena club offers
clean and sustainable self care products
all in one place without the markups
we're talking feel-good toxin free
essentials like deodorant tampons
probiotics and so much more it's a
one-stop shop for better products made
with simple ingredients well Jackie and
I love about Athena Club is the
convenience cleant cleanliness of the
ingredients and the excellent quality
all at an affordable price we also love
that Athena Club is the option for
subscription customization you can
include as much or as little you as you
need every month and it's all shipped to
your door subscriptions can start at
just $8 a month and that's sinking
feeling when you realize you're out of
must-haves that won't happen with its
FINA Club we manage our shipments to fit
our schedule so we never have to worry
about running out of something we need
the team at Athena Club believes you
should never have to stress about what's
going in on or around your body that's
why they only source clean sustainable
ingredients that are safe for you and
for the environment they're all about
transparency and they list every single
ingredient on their website athena club
offers a better self care routine made
simple
get 15% off your first order going to
Athena club comm and use the promo code
toast
that's athe nacl you be calm with promo
code toast for 15% off Thank You Athena
Club let's jump right in I just got my
box from Athena Club and they literally
have everything that I need for
self-care and everything like looks so
cute together in the uniform that you
don't even like feel like you need to
put away your shaving cream because it
matches your all-natural deodorant and
it matches like the new wipes that they
have um it was so good it was so
exciting to get and I feel like I've
been using their shaving cream recently
and I feel like I haven't used shaving
cream in like 10 years and it makes such
a difference I should let Dana know that
I have a shaving cream literally since
we used to have shaving parties on our
porches in camp where like we'd have
buckets of water and we would like shave
our legs before the dance yeah but like
honestly shaving cream is very
underrated and I love the Athena club's
okay let's get into the stories they're
pretty much all about relationships
today so we love a theme first up Cara
Delevingne and Ashley Benson break up
after nearly two years together ash Cara
Delevingne and Ashley Benson have called
it quits the model and the actress
reportedly split in early April people
reported on
Wednesday quote Cara and Ashley always
had their ups and downs before but it's
over now their relationship just ran its
course this I mean in a shocking one
yeah I'm taking this one particularly
hard I thought they were like true OTP I
thought they were so cool like chic
lesbians I'm so upset like this is
terrible and I have to assume early
April the cube must have had something
to do with their horn with their breakup
yeah I'm the Q is just like rearing its
ugly head in everyone's relationship
that's really the theme of this episode
um this is definitely a shock huge
because you know but it was a shock when
they were together and then like the
more they were not just like spotted
together they were a full-fledged like
in a relationship I thought it made so
much sense I was like they have all
found their place in this world like I
was so pleased me too and they both
seemed so happy and like at peace and I
mean maybe this is just like a temporary
Q induced breakup but maybe not and also
they had an interesting quarantine they
were quarantined with Kaia Gerber and
someone else like a star a man um so
like I just wonder I wonder what went
down they were like all in a house
together making tic TOCs and like
swimming and dancing and doing yoga
every day so something must have went
awry yeah I'm sure that was like all fun
and games for the first two weeks and by
week three it's like get the [ __ ] out of
my house like the party has to end
eight weeks of partying swimming dancing
yoga tick-tocking could you imagine know
like we remember the quarantine crew in
Florida yeah that feels like a whole
quarantine ago yeah that was like when
quarantine was like this
once-in-a-lifetime thing that like
people were really taking advantage of
having the time off they're like this is
never gonna happen ever again and then
it like went on for four months
back then we were naive we thought it
was gonna be like three weeks we were so
naive that first week of quarantine I
was just like yes I'm gonna eat like
everything no one's here to stop me and
then the next week I was like okay I'm
here by myself and I feel terrible you
know and then you have to learn how to
take care of yourself in the queue like
who are you gonna be in the queue and
afterwards um do you want to know who
I'm gonna be in the camp I'm gonna be a
piece of [ __ ] yeah I think in the queue
what I'm gonna be is like someone
who is severely like not happy but like
has a big mask on oh that's good I feel
like that's the way a lot of people feel
in regular life so I think a lot of
people can relate to that I actually
think the person I'm being in quarantine
is like so emotionally unstable like I
am having some of the highest highs and
then really really bad lows like it's
actually not healthy how unwell I am
yeah no I totally agree but like the
zoom patreon episode that we did with
all steams on deck when you guys pretty
much told me that like you think I'm
taking the quarantine the worst and I
had like no clue I thought I was doing
so well but I think what I realized is
like I was I thought I was doing well
it's showing you guys that I was okay we
saw through the mask
you saw through the mask yeah I don't
even know anymore I mean you know what
they're what today is it of kewda well
you know it we started on the 13th
today's May 7th so it's like 30 and 30
30 and 31 is 61 but so let's start on 13
7 so um 61 minus 6 what's that 50 55 5
day 55 I think we're in holy [ __ ] it's
like we're late gone by really fast but
like the days man are so slow like
yesterday we finished the toast and I
did everything in my power not to get
back into bed
I cleaned so hardcore did the dishes
like was literally wiping vacuuming
around Ben while he was working get back
into I get back into my bedroom sit down
it's 1:30 yeah that's rough actually had
a busy day yesterday because I was like
editing the redheads and just like
busying myself you know but that's why
it's nice to have a passion project
that's why it is nice have a passion
project but like now I have to wait
another two weeks well I still have to
read the book but that's that's not for
a while but anyways I just wish I could
find a way to like eat better because
then I know that I would feel better you
know do you mean better in terms of like
healthy or better in terms of like less
like Syria like less crap more yeah like
I feel like I'm gaining weight and that
makes me sad I don't think that you are
I just feel like I am
he eats so much yesterday it was crazy
but that wasn't usually I don't need
that much
I had a pop-tart this morning and I'm
just not mad about it and as much as I
spoke ill of the un-- frosted pop charts
they're done so so what it told me to do
is toast them and then put butter on
them but honestly like a pop-tart and I
know that I'm wrong because I remember
when we went to Dallas let me say that
your mother-in-law's she has the most
amazing pantry like filled with goodies
and I went and ate a pop-tart and she
was like didn't want to put in the
toaster oven and I was like excuse me
she's like they're meant to pop in the
toaster like I'm like are you sure and
she was like yeah and I put it in the
toaster and I like warmed it up and it
was good but like by no means was it
that different and up to me a pop-tart
is a snack
I get like for children it's a meal like
it's usually breakfast like for me it's
just a snack so like put a snack in the
toaster oven it's just to me a little
unnecessary um and I didn't mind
unfrosted I'm sure it would've been good
if I toasted and put butter on it but I
just wasn't interested
damn sometimes you just go with that
little extra step and it makes like your
meal gourmet and you do the way I don't
know you didn't treat yourself to that
and I feel like you deserve better
I'm like actually a lazy piece of [ __ ]
that's why and you know what I was
thinking before bed yesterday I'm
thinking of the next time I have to like
put on a full face of makeup because I
have not done that I don't think I'm
going to remember the steps so in the
last week of Q I have done like a full
face like for three times now for
different reasons one or the other and
it's been feeling great like you should
do it one day if you like with your new
sleep schedule since you're waking up a
little bit before the toast like you
should do it for the toast one day um
just like you know get that muscle
memory back but also you would just like
feel excited it's a new sensation it's
it that's what I'm looking for here is
some new sensations yeah house I'm gonna
start a band called the new sensations
that's really cute Oakley club called
the new sensations wears Theodora there
he is if you're watching on YouTube like
look at God I'm gonna get his attention
running vo no no no he's so happy no let
him be let him be let him be let him be
had
oh my god wait I just remembered my
dream I had such a vivid dream that I
went out about in town like gianna with
sentence track in Beverly Hills and we
had like this fabulous night we got like
so wasted she was like drunk driving me
around Beverly Hills and I was like
freaking out I ended up sleeping with a
different man and I woke up with such a
pin I was like did I have an affair like
I wasn't sure when I woke up and you
were like did I like sentence jack yeah
that was more shocking than me having an
affair like I was honestly it's such a
pity it felt so real like I really woke
up like I cheated on Ben and I felt so
bad but I didn't
yay Sutton is growing on me and I'm
looking forward to our Beverly Hills
recap yeah she's not necessarily growing
on me but she faded into the background
this episode and I enjoyed it yes
okay next story little relationship news
Logan Paul is dating Brody Jenner's ex
Josie Canseco hundra sont Logan Paul
confirmed this week that he is dating
Josie Canseco and the new couple are in
quarantine together amid the current a
virus pandemic quote I just want to live
a normal life but it's hard because I
put everything on camera so some things
I try to keep a little bit to myself he
told Entertainment Tonight on Thursday
he confessed that um so he was hesitant
to divulge too many details about their
relationship but he confessed that
Canseco does not check off all the boxes
on his list of what he looks for in an
ideal woman but he added I think the
idea is to get in the relationship and
grow with the person as they develop
traits you are attracted to
so while Josie definitely checks off the
majority for sure just like me we both
have stuff to work on okay that's a
weird quote but I'm gonna assume he was
taking like very much out of context
cause like yeah it sounded weird
I have something incredibly
controversial to say and I know you
agree with me I and I don't know like
the extent of YouTube drama I'm just
saying this is like someone with a pair
of eyes like I think Logan Paul is like
so cute okay like for me it always takes
a second to like um assemble the Paul
brothers because he's not the one that
dated that married in Vegas right Tanna
no okay yeah no I think both the Paul
brothers are really cute and they're
really successful and I think people
think that they're really funny
and their fellow podcasters and I really
ship this relationship like this seems
very um suitable do you remember when we
saw Logan Paul at Coachella with Lauren
Elizabeth we were like sitting and he
walked by and he was so tall and
handsome he had like 4,000 people with
him and like two skirts yards he was
probably also super tall because we were
sitting on the floor and we are tiny
right yeah I remember I know that he's
become somewhat of a polarizing figure
in the last few years um but I think
he's good and I'm into him yeah I'm into
the Paul brothers like vibe you know as
like fellow sisters in the game I just
they're like also really good brothers
well so that's the thing to me like they
were weird when they were like mortal
enemies and like people weren't sure if
it was really happening or if it was
like narratives and their YouTube videos
that they were literally sleeping with
each other's girlfriends and like they
[ __ ] hated each other and like to me
that was a real law low for the brothers
Paul um but now they like live in a
house together and I think like they're
really connected like they're in their
brotherly relationship and that's the
brothers Paul that I relate to and like
that I like but I think they were like
so trashy before that yeah I don't I
don't know about that era but like I
just feel like they're businessmen
entrepreneurs comedians and like I'm
here for it okay you know like where
they've landed in their careers like I
feel like for a while they were like
running amok and did they start on vine
um I don't know if they started on vine
but they were big on vine and that's
like what launched them got it so that's
just like feels like a whole yawn ago
but I'm just looking at this picture of
like him and Josie walking and like they
they look really cute and sweet
yeah Josie is like a girl about town yes
she is as she should be of course if I
looked like that I'd be a girl that town
too totally
okay ready for our next relationship
story is it the relationship story
that's brought to you by daily harvest
yeah actually it is I I thought you I
was hoping you would say that now more
than ever we realize how important it is
to try and eat right and daily harvest
makes it easy for us to do that they
keep our houses fully stocked with clean
food built on whole fruits and that
Stables Dalene Orbitz delivers delicious
clean food right to your door it takes
just a few minutes to prepare and we
never have any question if the food
we're eating is good for us everything
stays fresh in our freezers until you
are ready to enjoy it you don't have to
overthink any of your meals for the week
they have delicious options for any time
of day so smoothies for the morning
maybe a nice soup for lunch and a
harvest bowl for dinner you let me know
yeah flat breads which is fabulous and
tons of night I have a box of daily
harvest coming like legit today or
tomorrow I put in for delivery and I'm
so excited that's actually exactly what
I need right now when I want to like
pivot towards eating healthier but like
you know I still want to eat well and
enjoy my food daily harvest is gonna be
it for me daily harvest is also
committed to minimizing their
environmental impact so they're in the
process of transitioning to 100%
compostable recyclable packaging and are
over 50% of the way 50% of the way they
are already go to daily harvest common
enter the promo code toasty at $25 off
your first box that's promo code toast
for $25 off your first box at daily
harvest dot-com that's daily harvest com
Thank You daily harvest for being a real
one
I love daily harvest they're the perfect
thing right now um cuz I'm eating like
just crap
and I want good stuff so yeah harvest
let's go
okay next story lalla Kenan Randall
Emmet almost broke up quote a dozen
times in quarantine pregnancy plans are
on hold so the Wawa and Randall were
forced to postpone their April 18th
wedding due to the corona virus and now
while a joke that they pay not make it
down the aisle at all obviously like
this is kind of joking but like I feel
like she's really hitting on something
that's pertinent to every person in a
relationship in quarantine
she said well Randall and I have almost
broken up about a dozen times so you
know you this is definitely a test for
people's relationships but it's so crazy
because you know you just sit there and
you start bickering about little things
and you start over analyzing everything
and like we really have to just like
elevated our relationship in such an
amazing way she said I'm better together
with marina Menounos after laughing that
we Randall can't even put his own
laundry away and I'm literally going
through that right now there's a ball of
laundry of Zach's in the living room and
I know he'll get to it in the year 2020
but that's just like not quick enough
for me yes I and you know
like I would I would fold it but like
he's like like when we thought before
when we fought before him like I'm do
your own joke I told your lunch and then
he acts like that's not a big deal I'm
like oh you don't need me to do that
then I won't do that no no Jackie I've
reached my breaking point and it has to
do always with the chore it's like
literally I become I just talk and it's
like no one's listening and I'll be like
did you not put that away he's like did
you tell me to I'm like yes like what
are you deaf now it's so frustrating
literally and you know what it's like
I'm sympathetic like Ben is working a
full-time job like and he's actually
never been busier and like for the most
part I really don't know how much to do
afternoon so I really like when he's
making lunch I do the dishes like
sometimes I'm just like I've come in
here four times and ran for different
dishwashing loads like to Iran packing
ditches but what he makes like he's very
into tuna like he makes the smelliest
foods like there's dill all over my sink
like I just don't be like that should be
my burden and I don't think I'm
unreasonable in saying that no I don't
think so and for me like I totally agree
like I do the majority of the chores
like you think zach has ever scrubbed a
shower in his life um but like sometimes
there's just like a few things lying
around and like it's more soil point
like I could do them in two minutes but
like please do your dish throw away your
plate like whatever it is and then I'll
come back like six hours later and it's
still there and I'm like okay maybe I
didn't make this clear but like when I
asked you to do something like that like
could you do it within the hour like not
not by the time I wake up tomorrow
morning cuz that's usually what it is
he'll do it at like 3 a.m. and it no
just literally within the hour like if I
ask for something I need a time within
the hour and we've just about an hour I
wanted if I asked for it do it now like
it's unreasonable I'm just trying to be
like flexible ya know it's like
literally we've had and I'm like
whispering because he's in the other
room we've literally had this fight so
many times last night before bed like
it's got Joe Frazier with him I threw a
pillow at his face and who's being such
a drama queen like oh my god knows I'm
like oh my god shut the [ __ ] up and I
just got so frustrated I literally just
fell asleep
I just I couldn't be awake next to him
anymore like I just couldn't no I know
it's it's a trying time but even though
like obviously Lala is joking she said
like I know we're always gonna argue and
of course we're never really going to
end the relationship but you know you're
stuck
someone but there was you know we're in
such a good place I didn't even think we
could get any better I think it
definitely strengthens a good
relationship but it also the quarantine
also magnifies existing issues in your
relationship that aren't a big deal like
in regular day-to-day life they're not a
big deal but in the quarantine it's so
magnified that you start to analyze it
and say like oh my god is this like you
know a a sign of like of a bigger issue
in our relationship and it's like no
it's just like you're fighting more
about the laundry because there's more
laundry totally I have to do the laundry
today one of my least favorite activity
is yes I agree like everything is just
magnified and I can't tell with like
influencers and celebrities who are
pretending like the quarantine is like
so ingrained like we've been together
every day and it's a really not even
sick of each other like please stop I
know you're lying
yeah I feel like you could only say that
if you're in a very new relationship and
this is like such an exciting time to be
together but I feel as though a lot of
people like us and just toasters I feel
like a lot of people might be feeling
this way and it might be a relief to
just hear like it's not you or your
relationship like it's the quarantine
yeah and it's like don't do anything
rash it's just the quarantine yeah and
I'm not saying like you don't have
problems that are very real and that you
know you should work on them but like
you know don't rethink your whole life
unless like you know something that we
don't know this is something we talked
about a little bit in today's episode of
the redheads because the book that we
read really kind of talks about this
inner struggle between like being in a
situation that's good but you know
wanting something that's maybe better
and just questioning yourself um and one
of the redheads actually wrote in
because she the book inspired her to
break up with her boyfriend and we were
and she was just like wondering if that
was the quarantine talking so we need
some with some good advice um so I'm if
you're if you're grappling with these
questions honestly listen to the
redheads totally listen to the redheads
when they're podcasting for you boys
sound nice today listen to the redheads
he is a redhead big-time yeah
you ready for a next story I thought
you'd never ask
I'm Syrian already know I'm ready I'm
ready please I'm ready you don't look
ready I'm so ready
Lady gaga finally announces new
chromatic AX album release date wait uh
after the pop star previously postponed
her upcoming sixth studio album
initially set for release on April 10th
in the wake of the corona virus pandemic
she has finally confirmed the highly
anticipated LPS new launch date quote
the journey continues she said you can
officially join me on chromatic ax May
29th I feel like that's a good sign
that's a great sign I think that's also
perfect timing cuz May 15th weren't
letting the dogs out but you know in a
slow phased way probably and then by May
29 things will be escalating I'm really
feeling like a June first vibe and
chromatic is just the thing like I don't
need to ask you something and I don't
want to trigger you so obviously for
those who don't know Jackie and I live
in New York and the stay-at-home order
has been extended to extended till May
15th now we're approaching May 15th and
there's a chance that the governor will
actually push it back maybe to June 1st
a lot of people are saying maybe June
1st and I know you've kind of put all
your eggs in the basket of May 15 and I
just want to know like what you're gonna
say do or feel if May 15th comes and
like you're still staying inside um I
would have to take a look at all of the
information and facts that led the
governor to this decision and then I
know I'm no doctor or no politician but
I'm a person with a brain and I can
think for myself um but I will think
that it is a real shame
because I think that there are a lot of
different elements to this quarantine
obviously public health and public
safety being one of them but also
people's mental health and the ability
to have a job and to feed their families
and a limitless sense of purpose like
this is all wrapped up into one thing
and I will be seriously disappointed not
really just not for myself like what's
another 15 days in quarantine for me
like I will be seriously disappointed
for the city
um and if it gets extended I think it's
gonna get extended chill June first and
then I think we're like really in the
clear
I think but again I'm no doctor it's
just like a vibe I'm feeling like for
myself I'll cross that bridge when I got
there yeah a couple states have opened I
would like to see what's going on I
heard it lay that was opening is
everyone okay I want know I heard things
are going well and obviously like we're
not gonna open and every business is
gonna be open and things are gonna go
back to how they were on March 1st
but I think a phased reopening which is
what the governor is planning um is
prudent and I think that would be great
and now that the subways have been
cleaned I can go like them yeah I'm
excited for you to get your subway
looking in oh yeah okay well I'm excited
for Lady gaga - I think her albums gonna
be just the vibe like cuz when we get
out of the key like the parties are
going to be off the J don't stop and I
can't wait cuz her news like I think
this album is gonna be like everything
we've been waiting for do you think
we're gonna get a single before I don't
know album comes out I don't know if
there's time I know it's just so strange
to only get one single before an album
comes out I feel like sometimes people
do like two or three yeah but I feel
like one obviously everything's tossed
up into the air because of the pandemic
but - I kind of love this strategy it's
like here's the one single that sums up
what this entire album is about and this
song is [ __ ] fabulous if you're
interested in this song you will love
this album instead of giving us a taste
of different things and by the time the
album comes out we've heard 5 out of the
10 songs already I actually like when
there's a lot of signals because then I
feel like I'm already like in the album
and then when I get it there's like
stuff I already know it's like my second
year at camp you know yeah and then
there's not so much stuff you need to
learn because you're all caught up with
the material exactly I'm feeling I'm
feeling this I'm happy for you know that
I own this ok fifth and final story a
little positive business ah for one
business which is peloton peloton stock
heads for a record high after reporting
surge in pandemic purchases peloton is
getting too many orders too
fill them and losses are growing as well
as the company tries to get exercise
bikes two by two buyers forced to stay
home peloton Interactive Inc sales
topped 500 million dollars in its most
recent quarter a new milestone that
pushed the connected exercise equipment
companies young shares toward record
highs in after-hours trading peloton
reported that quarterly sales hit five
hundred and twenty four point six
million up 66 percent from the year
before thanks to a surge in sales for
its exercise bikes in the last few weeks
of the company's fiscal third quarter as
Koba 19 behind to spread into the u.s.
and fourth shelter-in-place
orders so I mean obviously this makes
sense that a company like peloton would
be doing well I'm happy for them because
they had like a couple of blunders
including that holiday commercial and
their IPO laugh and now their IPO was
laughed out a little bit to UM and
Isabella toaster myself and having used
the bike for I guess 55 days straight
now I love it I think this is a fabulous
company they're doing fabulous things
they started doing the I want ask the
pellet o sources so if you guys could
let me know because they started doing
live at home workouts their instructors
are at home on their bikes and they look
cute I did one once but is one of the
first ones and the quality was not good
some wondering if they're good now and
if you guys would recommend doing them
because I'm fine doing the old classes
from the studio like you know I'm an
evergreen [ __ ] so let me know what I
think to me like the most interesting
part of this story is just it's really
cool to see like what products and what
brands are successful in quarantine like
not a lot of them are and Spotify like
reported that their listenership is down
podcast listener skip is definitely down
a little bit people are just like
wanting to be stimulated more so it's
just so interesting I wonder what other
companies are like surviving during this
pandemic yeah Netflix is doing well
Rober Walmart oh yes supermarkets for
sure I wish I owned a supermarket for a
lot of whatever I want you know what's
interesting remember how we reported a
few weeks ago that SoulCycle was making
their own at-home bike I'm sure they're
just miffed they really missed the mark
I think the bikes when I was gonna order
a pallet on I was waiting to see what
SoulCycle when their bike would be and
it was said like end of May so I wonder
if people are gonna start to get them
soon but they like
we're just like a few months it's too
late yeah because part of the reasons my
peloton is so successful is like there's
no competitor no there are there are
like add their own at-home bikes but
there aren't like digital monitor like
community like they really are in their
own league yeah
they are trailblazers in the community
well there's also ignored ik track there
some that have like digital monitor what
not the peloton has that community you
know and the Pella toasters and it's
just great
I'm so happy so those are the fact
stories and I feel like you definitely
needed to know them um and now you do
okay and now that we know them we can
dive into Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills recap which aired on Bravo last
night and if we want to recap anything
else we watched it is all being brought
to you by material driven by the belief
that high performance skin care should
and can be non-toxic skin compatible and
affordable Natori am was born their
mission is to create safe clinically
effective biocompatible products that
deliver visible results all of their
products range from 16 to $25 but
they're as effective as formulas that
are triple or in some cases 18 times the
price nutriyums formulas utilize
cutting-edge technology to harness the
healing powers of ingredients found in
nature their products are proudly made
in the USA they are cruelty free paraben
free gluten free non-toxic fragrance
free and dermatologist tested they
believe it's impossible to achieve
healthy nourished skin with formulas
that are unbalanced or incompatible they
only use ingredients that are there
directly benefit the skin's health or
support the integrity of their formulas
with hundreds of ingredients banned on
their know list and an in-depth online
ingredient library nutrients number one
priority is safety and transparency we
have been on the nutrient bandwagon for
like two months now right yeah oh my god
I've been using nutriyums right since
the beginning of quarantine I use their
retinol serum oil and cream at night and
then their vitamin C serum and oil in
the morning I also use their green
something like a green juice face wash
in the shower and the multi peptide eye
cream and I feel like my skin in the
queue has never been better and I just
think that those two things are
definitely correlated thousand percent
and they're also they're offering a
special
if you wanna get that multi peptide eye
cream that jackie was talking about so
all toasters can receive the free multi
peptide eye cream with any purchase of
two items or more but you can only get
that at Natori I'm calm that's na T you
are
I um add an eye cream to any purchase of
two items or more and use the code toast
to receive the eye cream for no cost so
fill up your basket with what you need
use Koto's to get the free multi peptide
eye cream immediately add it to your
basket and it's fabulous it is fabulous
okay let's get into the Real Housewives
of Beverly Hills because we got a really
good episode last night yeah and Beverly
Hills for like 10 years and to me this
is like the first time I've really ever
seen like Kyle Richards crack yes she
was really like not in the right she's
kind of just like going at everyone for
like all these little things and maybe
it's because she wants to keep the drama
going on the show but like she wouldn't
do that at the expense of her own
reputation um the fact that she's like
so pressed about Drita and her glam and
B and her photo shoot like I thought
that was so judgmental and by the way
like saying that she has a life and even
if that life means that she got full
glam and then did a photo shoot like
Drita's like a kind of a bit of an
influencer and like her Instagram is so
premium like she is building something
for herself like I I would never I mean
I would never judge someone for doing
that because I would be the person doing
that but if one of my friends was having
an event and it was like pretty much a
come whenever say how long
um and I got like glammed up for it
obviously and I was taking pictures like
yeah I would be that late person but no
one would care like I don't know why
anyone would care that I'm late to me
like Teddy had such a weird way of
inviting everyone and it was from what I
saw like the way that jury decided to
attend the event was exactly what Teddy
wanted she did want anyone to feel
inconvenienced tired jury it did what
Teddy wanted her to do she came to
support but she didn't say for the whole
time because she didn't wanna do [ __ ]
yoga and boxing like I think Teddy was
probably happiest with derice way of
showing up like exactly I don't I
thought in her attempt to be chill like
this is exactly what everyone should
have done like jury came at a time she
stayed for long enough Denise was there
for an hour and a half like tarik came
for a substantial amount of time she
didn't inconvenience herself and she was
there to support like I don't know what
the
problem was so to me it's like first of
all jury literally did nothing wrong to
Teddy doesn't even care Kyle why the
[ __ ] do you care and then why are you
coming at literally everyone at this
dinner including Denise making fun of
her hair yeah she's just like off her
rocker
I don't know yeah I think like
struggling the bangs are terrible I
think maybe she's just struggling with
like working so much I think she might
be like sleep deprived and she's all
over running from North Carolina in New
York LA like I'm trying to give her the
benefit of the doubt because for the
most part like yes kyle has her
allegiance isn't she usually defends the
people she like wants to defend but she
really isn't like a crazy drama queen
like she's never really been like so
visibly wrong so something's going on
with her yeah you know what I think it
might be like on a deeper level other
than like obviously she's spread thin I
think it's not like she is the last aji
and she feels like this is her show her
group she might never say that because
she's classier than that but like the
she wants the train to run how she sees
fit and like she got up at 5:00 a.m. and
she's going to Teddy's thing like
everyone should be doing that and then
like do riously like to in Kyle's eyes
made her case worse by saying I have a
life but turns out having a life means
getting glam and taking pictures to Kyle
that's not much of a life but to me that
is like a very full exciting fun life no
but by the way like who the [ __ ] is know
Kyle to be the judgment of whose life is
better than someone else's like Tori was
busy [ __ ] off like who cares yeah and
like I think everyone knows that dirt
doesn't work out like she doesn't want
to put on boxing gloves that did not
look fun at all but I will say that a
ballroom the retreat especially in
watching it with quarantine eyes looked
heavenly I would give anything and also
to REITs per uh Denise's party after
that like the buffet the sundae bar the
alfresco dining like oh my God my
quarantine um Mike my quarantine little
green monster was so envious
yeah I agree one of my favorite parts of
the episode was seeing gar saw going out
to dinner with her sons like they're so
well behaved and I love gar sounds like
such a strict mom like with the
coca-cola I was dying I just love gar
Sal and I love that she didn't go to the
retreat like
said be chill I don't want to go
therefore I am not the whole thing was
so weird like the way that it was framed
and like clearly no one wanted to be
there they were like hiding in this room
the whole time even though it was a
really nice event it was really Teddy's
work event it'd be like having all of
our friends come to camp toast and
that's exactly how we would invite them
I come if you want to come like you want
to come to camp and like go all in but
like don't come just to support us cuz
we don't need can't baby see you yeah
like I do get that but so those women
shouldn't have gone no but like honestly
was just so funny watching him like eat
and drink everything at the hotel like
when they were up in that room fighting
and Eric it was eating that huge plate
of french fries it looks so good I'm
actually gonna wonder McDonald's today
like I just I love these women because
they're like yes Beverly Hills she she
she like they're always eating yeah they
love a good meal on a jury it was like I
just didn't eat another thing I think
that's literally all they did there that
day was eat something that was weird I
thought in the episode was their work
and this is something I Bravo's doing a
lot which is bothering me sorry it's two
things the first thing is that they keep
flashing back to meals the night before
two days before where the women like
what got together and it's like that
looks like something we should have seen
as like part of the episode like even if
there's no drama happening like I want
to see how these four women cuz was a
random group get along and like what's
the vibe at that dinner
totally and like not to be a [ __ ] but
like I would have preferred to have seen
four main cast members out to dinner
there was two of them that we messed
over seeing like Lisa Rinna out to
dinner with her daughter even though I
did love them getting paparazzi that was
so funny but like to me it's like it's
not where the show is not really about
that yeah I just want to say I really
felt like and I was waiting for at least
arena to give her daughter the
sunglasses when the paparazzi came
because Lisa Rinna obviously was like
hamming it up and her daughter was so
uncomfortable and like um she should
have given her her sunglasses that's
just I mean if anyone in the world
thinks that Lisa Rinna I did not call
this paparazzi herself like you are
crazy yeah obviously like she's so Rinna
about it and like loves to see them I
just felt for her daughter who was
clearly really uncomfortable and could
have used a pair of shades yeah she
should have handed them over actually
that never even occurred to me yeah that
was just like like I was like you
maybe because I feel like maybe because
I related to Amelia like I would be so
like um uncomfortable actually I don't
know I'm kind of a ham I don't depend
what I look like
of course yeah I don't know I would I
don't know I feel like I can like I have
two personalities one of them is Amelia
and one of them is Lisa Rinna so true
like cameras show up um let's talk about
Sutton because I think she was very
quiet this episode she definitely
changed some hearts and minds mind
slightly yeah I just want to say the
second thing that problem's been doing
that bothers me oh sorry so many
flashbacks like I would say 20% of the
episode is flashbacks of like someone
says something so we flashback to like
what something that we saw what really
bothers me is when they flashbacks is
something that just happened in the
episode like 20 minutes before and it's
like I was there we don't have amnesia
yeah yeah totally I was there um okay
Sutton so she was super quiet when she
like started really pulled up and she
like started to cry my heart broke for
her a little bit because it's obvious
that like she came into the show guns
blazing and they just like didn't work
out for her the way that she wanted it
to I'm sure she's a lovely person so I
will I'm willing to give her like a
second chance like I'll see where she
goes after this but I felt for her and
she didn't complain the whole day at the
retreat even though I know that that
retreat was literally like she just had
her knows about the whole thing the
whole time so I'm willing to look past I
felt for her um I sympathize with her
and I like I I just like that would have
been me in that boxing room like not
knowing which way to go and like just
being socially awkward and she's just
not cut out for it
um and her getting so emotional like
she's just a real person and I'm gonna
wipe the slate clean with her I have no
longer any preconceived notions about
her because she seems like a sweet woman
by the way you just hit the nail on the
head part of the reason why I think I
just didn't like her up front was like
everything was perfect and she's just so
fancy and so polite but it's like seeing
her cry in the back of a car in Malibu
like that's relatable I've done that
before like it really humanized her and
made me dance he is just like someone's
mom yes so like all this stuff about her
coming in in the place cards
honestly it all kind of tracks to her
being like socially awkward and that I
can relate to like going to a dinner
party
I don't know and not knowing where to
sit like I just would have internalized
all that but she's just like making a
thing about place cards like I think she
just is having a hard time like Garcelle
is just like a social butterfly
everybody loves her she could sit
wherever like you know not everyone is
that cool and so I kind of I feel sad
enough man
easy breezy wait one thing I didn't
mention that I think we need to talk
about he's like I get that Jerry was
upset with Kyle because Kyle is just
like coming at her for no reason but
like Verger eats our only response to me
that Kenny and Kyle have slept in the
same bed before like and then that whole
she was like are you calling me a
lesbian like what a dumb [ __ ] like
like that whole thing I was like great
you kind of lost me yeah that was like
out of nowhere
but we also didn't see the dinner before
where right Kyle said I what maybe Kyle
said I want to sleep here but I don't
have a bed and injury so we sleep with
teddy you slept with her before yeah
I'm feeling like they were filming and
like things were kind of boring but they
were going through the motions and then
all this Brandi didn't these stuff
happened and it like really shook
everything up so I feel like that kind
of rushing to that maybe that is a good
theory it does feel a little rushed but
maybe like the producers like maybe
nothing happened at that dinner but
sometimes like the dinners where nothing
happens where everyone's just like
getting along and being steamy and
having a good time like those are some
of the best scenes and looking fabulous
and looking fabulous to read it's just
like serving it up on another level that
little geometrical outfit with the hair
placement and the wedge is like was just
fabulous it was fabulous
I absolutely loved it I loved how her
and Erica though they both are like
bring it level 10 every single time have
like totally different styles like
they're each giving us something so
different each time and I can't get
enough of it same-same and Erica was
quiet this episode but I just love her
I just love her yeah I wonder what her
thoughts are on all of it yes she like
stayed out of it which obviously I
appreciated but I was genuinely curious
because to me she's like a real moral
compass like I would just love to know
what her thoughts were like who did she
think was being crazy yeah but you know
who I [ __ ] with so hard in terms
um morality Denise knows what up even
last season she smelled [ __ ] from a
mile away
with Camille I'm with Lisa Vanderpump
and tip I have not seen her be on the
wrong side of history yet granted it's
only been one season but she was right
throughout the dinner and she wasn't
even at the åland stuff that she missed
um and I just love that like you just
don't [ __ ] with Denise like she will
take up for herself like I would not
want to be arguing with Denise because
she's probably right agreed like she has
no stake in this like if the show
succeeds like she doesn't care all these
women like a lot of them Kyle Dury like
really depend on the show for fame for
money and they feel like it's a start-up
like they need to get the business off
the ground but with Denise it's like she
just walked in here she could leave and
she'll never look back it's not a big
deal so she doesn't really have to take
any side so she has no ulterior motives
like she really just is listening and
giving her opinion yeah and so and I
think like she's someone who if she were
my friend like I would go to her often
for advice because I think she just is a
wise person I agree I'm sure episode it
was a good episode um I feel like this
coming for Kyle is gonna be a big theme
up until Brandi and Denise um and oh the
biggest thing was that Kyle pretty much
said that you know she defends to read
all the time and that's the reason why
she's no longer friends with Lisa and
that seems like this undercurrent and I
was thinking about it and it's like Kyle
didn't break up her friendship with Lisa
because of to read ultimately it was
because of Teddy because Lisa was trying
to throw Teddy under the bus so Kyle had
to do what's right and inadvertently
have dreams back not intentionally but
just to prove that Teddy was being
manipulated you know what that's a very
astute observation jacking so just
something to think about
yeah maybe that'll come up I feel like
we haven't gotten this in depth on an
episode in a while well it was like the
only thing on last night and I didn't
watch anything else no but sometimes
like sometimes it calls for it I don't
know there's no rhyme or reason
sometimes the biggest episode it's just
like we're like oh my god shook crazy
ya know and that's what I think the
producers like sometimes they get wrong
about it's a day one
crazy dinner flippin sometimes I just
love like fabulous women getting
together being fabulous eating fabulous
food and just like living fabulous lives
yeah me too me too
but I love a dinner flick table flip -
yeah I feel yeah um okay anything else
before we wrap up it was a nice long
episode we got yeah no I think that's
all she wrote like I'm looking at her
and so she's done writing oh yeah
sex to me she said I'm done writing oh
okay cool
so that's all she wrote thank you guys
so much for listening to the morning
toast the Millennial morning show where
we go live Monday through Friday 10:30
a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube so if
you're watching us on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcasts can be
found so that's Spotify iTunes stitcher
Public Radio I already know cast box all
the places where ever you listen to
podcast find this morning Tesla five
star review about a beautiful stunning
and smart we are love you guys have a
great day we'll see you tomorrow bye